[Música]
y llegó el momento de actualizar la
información económica en directo a
América por ello le doy la bienvenida a
mi compañero Jorge Hurtado Jorge cómo
vamos muy bien Andrés y vos Bien también
Jorge vamos a iniciar hablando de Reino
Unido a propósito del informe de la ocd
bueno Reino Unido tendrá la inflación
más alta de la mayoría de países
desarrollados en 2023 esto según el
informe de la ocde el organismo dice que
la inflación general británica se
situaría en el 6,9% de 2023 por encima
del 6,3 de Alemania y del 6,1 de Francia
y de la media de los países de esta
organización que rondaría el 6,6% de
inflación anualizada un dato importante
es que según las proyecciones también de
la ocde la inflación británica se
ralentizaría hasta el 2,8% en 2024 sería
incluso más baja que en Francia y
Alemania este jueves el Primer Ministro
británico Richie visitará Estados Unidos
con el fin de construir una alianza para
según el proteger las Industrias clave y
salvaguardar las cadenas de suministro
pero es una tiene como principal desafío
la inflación que ya modifica los hábitos
de consumo de los británicos e incluso
obliga a familias a acudir a los bancos
de alimentos así lo cuenta desde Londres
Luisa Pulido y Anita Montalvo
Pablo vi desde hace 10 años en Londres y
trabaja tiempo completo los últimos dos
ha tenido que ser creativo para hacer
rendir su salario impactado por una
inflación anual que ronda los dos
dígitos en realidad ahora Estamos
comprando más marcas del supermercado
las más baratas y cocinando un poco más
básico estamos comprando un poco menos
de carne quizás
Estamos buscando los las ofertas
Valentina y su pareja También tienen un
trabajo estable sin embargo el aumento
de los precios de los alimentos debido
al alto costo de producción del
transporte de la caída en la cosecha de
países productores y los efectos del
brexit ahora compra productos de menor
calidad sí Para ser honesta hemos
recortado mucho porque hemos notado Un
aumento en los precios de todos los
alimentos básicos solo artículos como
mantequilla queso leche normalmente
intentaríamos comprar productos
orgánicos para estar en el lado más
saludable pero finalmente tuvimos que
recortar de muchas maneras solo
alimentos básicos como huevos y queso
ahora volvemos al mínimo que podemos en
el templo de Kensington ubicado en el
vecindario
millones de dólares se ven filas de
ciudadanos que acuden a buscar alimentos
y artículos de aseo un hecho poco común
hasta hace poco en Londres al pastor
Eddy le preocupa que en el 2020 llegaban
al menos 20 personas en la actualidad
reciben las 80
es como
no mejorado se ha vuelto más desafiante
familias enteras están siendo
desalojadas en Londres los propietarios
están subiendo el alquiler todo tipo de
cosas es todo el efecto de la bola de
nieve Así que mirándose delante soy
optimista
mientras el gobierno británico Busca
alternativas para aliviar la crisis
estudia un acuerdo con los supermercados
para que reduzcan los precios de los
alimentos básicos incluso a Costa de
sacrificar parte de sus ganancias Jorge
vamos a otro país que enfrenta una
histórica inflación se trata de
Argentina y allí el gobierno propone
medidas para aliviar los precios bueno y
el gobierno anunció la exención del
llamado pago impuesto a las ganancias
sobre el sueldo anual complementario que
también es conocido como aguinaldo Y que
se paga al fin del primer semestre o sea
el 30 de junio de cada año según el
Ministerio de economía medio millón de
trabajadores argentinos se beneficiarían
de esta exención tributaria según dijo
el gobierno es un beneficio
extraordinario por única vez que alcanza
el 50% de los trabajadores que hoy pagan
este impuesto a las ganancias con el
único objetivo dice de que repongan el
poder adquisitivo ahí los ingresos son
golpeados por una inflación anual del
108% que creció un 32% en lo que va de
2023 Argentina vive una de las peores
alzas de precios en todo el planeta
Jorge y ahora hablábamos de fútbol pero
con un enfoque económico con el anuncio
de Messi de jugar en el Inter de Miami
Bueno lo que sabemos hasta ahora es que
Messi rechazó una propuesta de los
auditas que le pagarían 400 millones de
dólares por temporada que ofreció el
Inter de Miami para que
lograr este fichaje bueno según el medio
de athletic El acuerdo incluye un
porcentaje de los ingresos de la mls Paz
el paquete de transmisión partidos por
televisión recientemente esta liga firmó
con Apple los derechos para transmitir
diez temporadas a cambio de 2500
millones de dólares esto reforzaría la
estrategia deportiva de Apple que lanzó
un documental del argentino y una de sus
series más vistas en el servicio de
streaming a propósito trata sobre un
equipo ficticio de la Premier League que
es entrenado por un estadounidense Messi
también tendría participación en las
ganancias de Adidas que ya lo patrocina
y que también paga publicidad en esta
liga La Movida es un golpe de suerte
para Adidas que pasa a puros tras el
colapso de la franquicia Jessi después
de que se cancelara su asociación con g
del rapero antes conocido como kanye
West la llegada a Estados Unidos le abre
el camino a Messi a trabajar con marcas
globales e incluso a tener participación
en acciones del Club en su última
temporada como un dato interesante Messi
ganó 3,6 millones de dólares por mes con
el psg en Francia y bueno con estas
cifras cerramos la información económica
Jorge muchas gracias seguimos con más
aquí en directo América
[Música]